- When Childish Gambino
released the music video
for "Feels Like Summer," it
almost immediately hit the top
of every trending page.
The visuals show a cartoon
Gambino strolling down the street
on a hazy summer day.
Throughout the neighborhood,
63 different black artists
and figureheads are in typical,
summer-related scenarios.
Everyone on Twitter gave their thoughts
on the different meanings
behind the video.
We spoke with character
designer Justin Richburg
and co-director Ivan Dixon to
see how it all came together.
- [Justin] Part of my thing
is to make sure I capture
everything as crystal clear as possible.
- [Alana] Justin Richburg is an artist
known for putting well-known
figures in unlikely
and many times controversial scenarios.
His black history month
piece, "Dice Games,"
went viral and created
quite the reaction online.
It also grabbed Gambino's attention,
so much so that he put
the piece in an episode
of his show, "Atlanta."
- Like a week or so
later, after, you know,
I quit my job, I made
the dice game picture
and then it happened just
like that, that quickly.
- So for that particular
photo that did go viral,
you do, you know, create some
controversial stuff sometimes.
- Yeah I mean that's on
purpose, because, you know,
a lot of times when I talk
in regular life, you know,
I offend people real easily.
Might as well just put it in my artwork.
- [Alana] How long did it
take, from start to finish,
to sketch out 63 different celebrities?
- [Justin] I think two months, maybe.
- [Alana] Richburg did
say he wished he had
a little more time perfecting
some of the characters,
including Whitney Houston's curls.
- With my style, doing
that type of curly hair
is kinda difficult, like
you trying to keep it simple
for the animators to copy.
They kept on starting
over and over and over,
and then like I'm trying
to get her eyes correct
and all that, at the same
time trying to keep it simple
as possible for them, you
know, to be able to mimic.
- [Alana] Once the character
designs were created,
the animation team then
began storyboarding
based on Gambino's instructions.
- [Ivan] It's a celebration of culture.
Finished the video on the
Friday before it launched
and we, that was like I was
compositing shots that day.
So we never even got a
chance to watch it back,
and do quality control, you know,
we just delivered the
thing and it went live.
So Donald already had a
pretty extensive brief.
We were tasked with interpreting
the bullet-point brief
into a storyboard.
Justin designed 60-plus characters.
- [Justin] I told them they
should do it like a "Bebe Kids"
type of background, I
didn't wanna like, step over
my boundaries, you know, I just
wanted to let you do enough
and then let them do
what they needed to do.
- [Alana] Gambino took
Ivan and the animation team
through Atlanta's streets to get a feel
of how the visuals should look.
- We used Google Maps and
wandered the streets of Atlanta,
trying to get, absorb as
much of the scant knowledge
as we could.
- [Ivan] Lyrically, my
interpretation of the song
is that it's about global
warming and climate change.
- That informed the color
choices of the background.
Donald was pretty clear
he wanted it to feel
hazy and polluted.
Donald dictated the order of events.
We only deviated a couple of
times for staging reasons,
but he'd already paired up all
the people with each other.
- While Dixon did say that
many of the situations
that were storyboarded
were sheer coincidence,
Gambino did get the final
say on the finished piece.
And a couple of situations
definitely stood out,
like the scene where
Travis Scott knocks down
Nicki Minaj's blocks.
Many have interpreted this
scene to be about Scott
knocking Nicki out of the top spot
of the Billboard 100 charts,
and how Nicki was not here for it.
- He didn't have the number one album,
"Queen" was the number one album.
- [Ivan] It takes a couple of weeks
for it to be storyboarded,
designed, and animated,
and we had already done
that before any of this
latest conflict happened.
Yeah, call it a premonition.
Originally, the brief, I think it said
they were playing Jenga,
but we had to drop that
for legal reasons.
Donald had indicated that he
wanted some of the characters
to appear against a black
background during the chorus,
we decided we'd have Donald
close his eyes and stop walking.
I can't speak to his
decision for who appeared
in that section, but we definitely knew
there was like a somber kind of vibe,
everyone had their eyes closed.
- [Alana] Dixon and Richburg both say
that there are a few
characters people online
keep mixing up,
and no, this isn't XXX.
Did you catch any references
we might have missed?
Let us know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe.